welcome back to 8701 so in this
section of our discussion of
instrumentation
we talk about accelerators and i'll do
this in a in a little bit of an historic
way
showing you some of the developments
over the last
up to 100 years
you know we use electromagnetic fields
in order to accelerate
charged particles and so the
developments
in electromagnetism and understanding
electromagnetism
led to then you know the technical
developments of the technological
development
of accelerators and availability of
devices which can be used in order to
accelerate
or modify particles and so this goes
back to maxwell
and hertz discovering electromagnetic
waves
towards jj thompson who
was able to use cathode rays
and classical lawrence force in order to
understand the electromagnetic fields
if we study uh particle accelerators we
can see
three different historic lines the
direct voltage
accelerators resonant accelerators and
transformer accelerate and so we go
through those three different
subjects one by one the energy limits
of our accelerators they're typically
given by the maximum possible voltage
available
when you're thinking about accelerators
used
for colliding beams um it's not just
the energy which is a limiting factor
but you also need
a sufficient number of particles to be
accelerated
and brought to collisions and those
particles need to be
in some sort of beam which is narrow
such that collisions are possible
requirements change depending on whether
or not you have colliding beams or fixed
target experiments
whether or not you actually study lepton
collisions or
headround collisions uh whether or not
you're using secondary particles as
the means of what you're going to learn
from this but the concepts are
very comparable across those individual
fields of study
so let's start with the vandermeer van
der graaf accelerator
so you basically you know have to
be able to create large voltages and for
the wonder graph accelerator
is being doing is creating this large
voltage by just
moving particles um
particles from from one level separating
particles to create this large voltage
um you can typically get up to you know
mega volts and tens of mega volts of
of voltages um but you may need to make
sure that you don't
enter a breakdown kind of regime and so
it depends on what kind of insulating
materials you use
you know if you are in using insulating
gas
under certain environmental conditions
you get up to
17.5 mega volts which then can be used
in order to accelerate
you can use the fact that you can use
the electric field
twice in the tandem accelerators by you
know just changing
uh changing the direction of the voltage
um large potential differences have been
you know have been a field of studies in
the in the 1920s and 30s
and um one you know not so
and it's just noteworthy that this is a
dangerous field so brush and langer
they used potential from lightning in
the swiss alps but
this was fatal for longer who was
electrically electrocuted fatally
on by lightning strike
so then you need to think about how can
you make your large voltages available
and how can you make them available for
acceleration
um quakkrov walton accelerators
use a sequence of a cascade generator in
order to
you know reuse the voltage in order to
create a larger potential for
acceleration
the marks generator is very conceptually
very very similar
[Music]
those are still used today so we know
why those developments are
uh you know 80 or 90 years old um
you know if you go to a physics today
article from 2003 you see that a machine
like this is being used
um in order to create the initial
confinement for fusion
reactors and the total power is
rather fascinating 4 terabytes which can
be released in 100 nanoseconds
from a larger number of those marks
generators
in modern particle physics accelerators
we use
uh resonant acceleration quite a lot and
the idea is really like it's shown in
this picture here
that the charged particles they're kind
of being accelerated on a wave
so basically they're surfing on
electromagnetic waves
and this can be seen here you just place
them correctly in your waveform
on a specific point and then they can be
accelerated
over some distance so the the key
point here is that you have uh
a proper or correct phase relation uh to
the accelerating voltage
and the setup can be you know varying
and historically there's
various attempts to do this in an
optimal way
the first one is the cyclotron which you
know has a static
magnetic field and in each turn
you know your particles are being
injected and then
in each turn your particle is getting a
kick here and a kick here and
because their velocity is increasing
their radius
in a fixed magnetic field is increasing
as well
so at some after some time the is
accelerated and leaves the cyclotron
with a specific velocity
focusing here is important you don't
want to just inject particles and then
they'll spray all over the place
and you know in accelerators four sticks
and having the right optics for
the particle is a key part of the work
work needed here there's a number of
techniques
i don't want to go into too much detail
but what you
typically see is if you compress the
beam in one direction
it decompresses in the other direction
and so quadruple
magnets can be used in order to you know
get some focusing and you use um you
know fringe fields and edge fields in
order to make sure that the beam itself
stays in a compact form you can also you
know
do techniques where you know you have a
initial focusing in one direction and
then in the other direction so the
resulting b
can be made made smaller
accelerators are not just important
today in
particle physics but they are
specifically
found their place in medical
applications in tumor therapy
specifically and the history here is
very long you see those initial
ideas or methods where neutrons are used
10 mev neutrons are used in order to
treat
tumors um we haven't discussed this in
nuclear physics too much but when you
use ions as a radiation form you can
really pinpoint where energy is
deposited
um the so-called black peak is used in
order to you know
precisely figure out in a
three-dimensional way where the energy
of them
of the ions is being deposited this is
in contrast to
radiation tier with these photons where
you just basically spray a larger part
of
the live life material and you know just
destroy the cancerous cells but also
the ones which are still healthy um
you know any given larger hospital
nowadays has a small accelerator
and so there's thousands and thousands
of those available
and the work and the maintenance of
those is rather important
but continuing the discussion of
accelerator concepts
um you know this kind of racetrack
accelerators
um are quite interesting you basically
have a couple of
uh fixed nets and your particles being
injected
and is you know getting like in the
cyclotron larger and larger kicks
and then at some points can be ejected
in order to do experiments
again this is not the technology which
is you know not
used anymore mummy is an accelerator at
university of mainz and it's it's um
the next generation is using the next
generation of accelerators at this
facility is using
a similar technology
the question is you know what kind of
conditions you have to fulfill in order
to keep the particles in place
and here you know because the particle
moves along it in each turn takes more
time in order to make
one circulation so what you want to make
sure is that
your face and the acceleration stays
in in sync so you want to make sure that
you know the particle
when it comes around again gets another
kick and it's not de-accelerated
and so that explains why in those
machines uh
the particles are bunched they come in
little blocks of particles
instead of just being a continuous
stream of particles and you can work out
the conditions
are necessary in order to fulfill the
requirement that particles are being
continuously accelerated
um so then there's you know over the
history
a number of technologies which which
make
try to make use of the fact that when
you accelerate the velocity of the
particles increases
so initially at a specific time
with one sequence the particle gets
a kick and then in the next time it's
already faster
it needs it travels further so you can
there's video
linux linear accelerator structures you
just increase the length of
each accelerator structure in order to
make sure that
you again can give particles the
necessary kick
nowadays we use cavities and we use
superconducting cavities in order to
make some energy efficient in order to
have large gradients
uh the general idea is again that you
know you place your particle in here
and you place it such in your face in
your electromagnetic
varying electromagnetic fields that it
always gets a kick
instead of being on the other side and
being de-accelerated
again the alvarez linux is a very
similar concept
um the advantage here is that you only
have one power input
which then you couple and you know the
walls of the machine don't dissipate
energy
so then the next you know once you have
an accelerator structure in place
you also want to make sure that the
structure itself doesn't interfere with
the beam
that the power transfer is as efficient
as possible
um such that you can you know get four
more for your buck
all right i mentioned this a few times
already the
you know the the fact when you have
an electromagnetic wave of this form and
you put your particle
here the question is what happens with
particles which have a slightly higher
energy
or with particles which have a slightly
lower energy and it turns out that you
know this kind of wave has a
self-focusing kind of structure
in a sense that you know the particles
were a little bit behind
they get a little bit larger kick
particles which are a little bit in
front they get a little bit
lower kick which means overall in energy
you focus your bunch and energy and
space
will focus a bunch you can go one step
further using
if quadrupoles again no details given
here
you use those units in order to further
squeeze the beam
and reduce the footprint in energy and
space
the phase space your particles are
occupying
all right you you know
the the next level here is then to use a
better tron
and the idea of the betatron is that
you change the magnetic field as you go
instead of changing the size of the
structure you change the magnetic field
so you can use the same structure
in order to confine your beams and the
the next level to this is that you just
use one magnet
use many magnets and this is done in
encyclotrons modern synchrotrons
um so here again a large
line in history but the point is that
you know when you
use the same orbit for the particles why
you accelerate them
your magnet structures can become much
much smaller
so you have many small magnets instead
of one large magnet
and only one or a few accelerator
sections are needed
so the particle passes by here it's
being accelerated
and then you have magnets of course the
link as the
ring which is which are able to change
their field strengths um you know again
if you have constant field strengths
the radius changes but if you're
modifying the field strength accordingly
to the speed of the particle
you can keep particles in the same
circular structure
more words on the focusing again if you
if you space the magnet such that
there's a gradient in the fields between
depending on the position you can use
that fact in order to
have particles which are further out
being bent more inwards
particles which are further inwards and
more outward this is called weak
focusing
and you can do this not just once but
twice by changing the rotation and then
that's that called
strong focusing
synchrotrons have limitations um there's
two which are rather important the first
one
the radius of the synchrotron is
determined by the momentum of the
particle
and your magnetic field so at some point
you run into technical limitations on
the magnetic field strength
modern superconducting magnets they get
up to
in the order of eight nine tesla we are
able to produce
accelerator crate magnets of up to 14
tesla
using superconducting materials and so
that gen
with a fixed size of your tunnel of your
ring
limits the amount of momentum you can
give or energy you can give to your
particle
and so for the
lhc we accelerate protons up to 70 ev
in one beam and we use the magnetic
field of 8.4 tesla
so that's really the maximum the machine
can actually deliver and we haven't
actually demonstrated that we can get up
to this point right now
the center of mars the important energy
is
6.5 tv the previous concept
and construction had started in texas in
the united states
in the so-called ssc tunnel which much
much larger
acquired 87 kilometer an 87 kilometer
tunnel
the idea was to get protons to center to
energies of 20 tv
with magnets of 6.8 tesla
okay this is one limitation the size of
your tunnel the second one is
when you bend a charged particle
with a magnetic field it radiates and it
radiates
proportional of the energy proportion of
energy over mass
to the fourth power which means that
you at some point are limited
by the power you have to invest in the
beam to even just keep it at a specific
energy
so this is e over m
[Music]
n to the fourth power
and um this also gives you a clue why we
actually accelerate protons in the lhc
and not electrons
the electron mass is too low and you
know this goes to the fourth power here
the the lincoln radiation of electrons
in the lhd tunnel is just the limiting
factor at some point you don't have
enough power anymore in order to give
that to the electrons or the particles
in order to accelerate them
all right so as i was saying initially
so you need
focusing you need accelerating and you
need
you know all kinds of additional
components to
an accelerator in order to make good
colliding beams
and so it's much easier to just dump a
beam into a fixed target and study
what's coming out so colliding beams as
a source for input into particle physics
experiments came a little bit later
first concepts came to fruition and
fascadi in the 1960s
and then we had spear a electron
positron collided
in center of mass energy of 4 gb which
then led to the discovery of the jsi
um and then later we had a
5 gb electron position collider which
was then
designed for for 8gb this then
continued
[Music]
as you know to machines like lab
which had a center of mass energy of up
to 210 gev
and the lhc the center of mass energy of
design of 14 tv
so the collider elements what do you
need um
you need to inject particles and so you
have to have a source of electrons
and the source of positrons producing
positrons is just
you know technologically in large
numbers much more complicated than
electrons
um here you can you know just
in order to get sufficient electrons you
need to actually
um produce them with a
kind of an accelerator structure as well
and so then they you know need to be
focused they need to be cooled down
in order to have them as a beam being
injected in the structure
so you what you need as additional
components you need your
your i have generators you need magnets
to bend the beam in and out um you need
to
have magnets in order to bend the beam
around so we need bending magnets you
need focusing magnets to keep
the beam in orbit and then you want to
before you bring them to the collision
you want to further focus the beam such
that you have more
actual particle collisions available and
then you have interaction points where
you will put your particle physics
experiment
um what's being done here in this in
this facilities is you
you inject you accelerate and then you
store the beam
to make sure that you can fully exploit
the structure so
those strings are called storage rings
you avoid you know having a one kind of
short kind of mentality as you have for
example in linear machine
sometimes you do this in separate rings
sometimes you do this in the same ring
that depends on the design of the
machine the challenges are
if you have particles travel around for
hours that they shouldn't interact with
some
gas for example in your accelerator
structure you require
a very very good vacuum in order to not
lose the beam
as you have it stored the fields of your
accelerator structures need to be very
stable and that stable
they have to be stable for many many
hours that for example there's some
some requirements on on your uh
electric grid for example such that you
know you have the stability in voltages
which
don't end up changing the
actual field strength of your magnet as
you go along
um yeah so again i already mentioned
this the further developments of those
machines
um you know in the 80s at cern
you know stochastic cooling was used for
the first time
in an anti-proton portrand machine
and that machine led to the discovery of
the w and the z bosons
and and first really deeply study of the
weak interactions at the scale of the
weak interaction
um at the tabletron in close to chicago
um you know protons and antiprotons were
brought to connect
collisions at the thermal at fermilab at
the fermi national accelerator
laboratory
um and then lab started in the late
1980s
in the same tunnel as we find today the
lhc
at daisy in hamburg
hera was used to collide electrons with
protons
and those results send that to an
understanding of the structure of the
proton
so you see that the reason why i show
you this history here is
that the the progress we did in particle
physics
at the energy frontier each of the
energy frontiers
was very much tied to the progress in
accelerator
structures and rightfully so um simon
fundamenta received the nobel prize
in physics as an accelerator physicist
for the discovery of the w and z button
um he was working on the machine and
made the machine possible
together with scala um
an interesting if you look at the
history of those particle accelerators
it's interesting to see how
you know we made move the energy
frontier forward so what you see in this
plot here is
the available energy of the machine and
what you see here is
line and this plot is called a living
plot you see the logarithmic scale and
you saw that for a very long time
there was this logarithmic increase in
available energy
so this line is now turning over and
we're already in 2020
and we haven't made any progress here so
broke us here um there is however
interesting discussions on
going somewhere and going too high going
somewhere here
um with the next machine and being able
to probe further higher energies
and the way this is proposed for
proto-important collision is by just
making a structure similar to the lhc
but with the radius about four times
larger
about 100 kilometers inc compared to the
24 27 kilometers there that she has
today
and so you can compare this with the
hutron machines but also the electron
machines and also on the electron
machine slide
this this trend is not as pronounced as
for the protein machines
but basically here the highest energy
electron positive collider is still lab
which is being decommissioned at the end
of the last century
and we are thinking about the next
machine um you know sometimes you see
those acronyms
as a linear machine international linear
collider or a future circular collider
with electron and positron collisions
which would be host in the very same
tunnel as this machine which is called
fcc
ppp or hh
hh with 100 it's kilometer conference